marketing is changing dramatically in a
world where we all know in here that we
don't watch that many TV commercials
outside of the Super Bowl brand
integration into the thing we're
watching the game is very important so
whether it's things like the patch or
things like social media and streaming
services actually eating up the majority
of people in this room's attention not
print not Direct Mail not television
commercials we grew up with the
landscape is changing dramatically
whether you're a big business or whether
you are literally a human in here that
wants something to happen understanding
how to make the pictures and the videos
and the written words for these
platforms is the Battleground only thing
I do for a living for the last 25 years
is really just trying to figure out
where the attention is and how to be the
best at filling that attention with
information